Jimmy Lovato who nailed this Christina  impression on Fallon last week told  Samantha Harris about her raw new music  video for stone cold and only we have  the first look  it was actually the hardest music video  I've ever shot I was actually thinking  about my grandmother he wasn't doing so  well in the hospital  if happy as her and happy for you and it  was just kind of like okay if this is  your time like then I'm I'm okay with  that I love you I kind of related it to  that experience that I was going through  she's doing a lot better now so I'm  excited  and something else getting Demi excited  her new tool this time though with Nick  Jonas we just opened up our own record  label not only are we really good  friends but we're also business partners  now